Melby sets the record straight on
reports that she's entering rehab next
month you announced that you're gonna be
entering a treatment program and that
must have been a lot this weekend well I
kind of got a bit skubick okay
as Lea Michele takes over as a guest
host for Ellen DeGeneres Mel explains
the real reason she's seeking help you
know no I'm not an alcoholic
no I'm not a sex addict you know I was
with the same person for ten years and
it was quite a thermal very intense
that's all I can say about it I'd like
to say a lot more boys keep it PC but
yeah I address a lot of those issues and
I did kind of have to ease my pace Mel's
best friend Gary echoes her sentiments
telling et quote she's not sex addicted
at all she's working on herself she's
currently and has been seeking therapy
for PTSD for roughly four to five weeks
the former Spice Girl says her book will
discuss her history with post-traumatic
stress disorder at Lynn Gary adds after
reading her tell-all it will be more
clear what she's going through right now
I mean the best thing is just to watch
your kids grow and develop as for how
this is affecting her three kids Phoenix
Angel and Madison her best friends help
ET her children are her focus quote
she's a very good mother she takes her
kids to piano gymnastics and the four of
them do a lot of activities together all
agree the great kids
you